hello
are we live i think
wow
hello hello
[Music]
i think we're live should be working
well good morning
how are we all doing
today welcome
what time is it over there it is
almost 11 am
what up guys
hi oh i don't have to do this anymore i
i always forget that i have no music or
sound effects
going on
see who
sakira right yeah
the reason i don't have music or sound
effects on is because i've been playing
the entire game on mute
and just voice effects
just so i can record every single bit of
dialogue in the game without any weird
background noise
just so the videos will be better
thank you paleblet
hi jars
it's going good infamous
what's the next video idea
i don't know yet
i don't know yet
we'll see though
oh and i can turn my hood on that's nice
okay
i think where did we end
last week
and we have a lot more to do oh my god
okay
we could potentially go anywhere
we could try the dungeon at the
beginning actually
is it called stranded graveyard
no cave knowledge
i have not made a video on the frenzied
flame now
oh this never mind
that's the tutorial
hi kyle how are you man
oh i put chad on the screen too because
a bunch of people were complaining about
that
i don't have a key are you for real dude
oh i know where i used it
i used it over here didn't i i did
where's another one okay we did all that
down there
you know what there's a lot of caves we
could go to i don't i don't know why i'm
stressing this let's go
here
jeez you're going all the way home
meat
any reason
i'm going for that any of my second
playthrough got the eyes and [ __ ]
oh you're going for the frenzied flame
ending nice
hello piggy
by the way if you guys want to follow
along with the boss list
because we're trying to do every single
boss in the game
you can go to the description and there
will be a link to a giant list of every
boss in the game
and you can see the progress
oh yeah there are wolves down here
now
why do the dogs try to um
they don't even try to bump or bite you
well yes they do
they like
tackle you it's really odd
do anything fun today not yet
i'm watching the pga championship today
oh god
that's why i got started a little bit
earlier
is this a new character i would say
we're like four hours in i think
three hours in
i appreciate that austin thanks
i think we'll be okay
man
what a difficult boss
all right check it off the list
golf pog
if you go to my twitter you can see um
i'm almost i've almost got my whole golf
set done i've got uh i just need a
driver and a five wood left
i got my irons i got my wedges i got my
putter
i got a new bag
it's very nice
hardest boss soldier of godric i did die
to it in this playthrough but it's
because i was memeing
i was trying to parry it and i'm not
very good at parries
um
we could do crucible night i guess
soldier of godric is impossible
what i'm saying man
right i'm gonna make the excuse that i
was meaning
when in reality i was trying really
really hard and i'm just bad
yeah then you get the pharah missoula
and those guys can like one shot you
with 50 bigger almost
[Music]
what are the remembrances for
that you can use them for souls or to
get
souls you can use them to get
uh
oh my god runes
or you can use them
sister free to build how much trouble
did you have with her pretty mean
sister frida
how much trouble do you have with her oh
my god dude if you really want to see
how much i struggled with
sister freda
you could go to my twitch that i have
not streamed on in a long time
go back like four months
and i'm pretty sure it took me like two
days to beat her but thank you for the
five dollars that's very kind of you
yeah you can you do remembrances for uh
you can get runes or you can turn them
into
the two fingers lady at the round table
and you can get uh boss items
that's why you get 60 vigor exactly
exactly
all right crucible night
not a good start
about as bad as it gets actually
wow
he is going off
okay
[Music]
huh
can i use my physically sir
okay that was almost what i wanted to do
yo what's up brody how you doing man
good to see you
come on bro
[Music]
right under the tail sweep under the
tail
i beat renault and i don't know where to
go
anywhere your heart desires
ah
you could go to altus plateau you go to
volcano manor go to the capitol
you could go underground
oh come on
there's lots of places you can go
go ask gideon
freaking tail dude
nice
are you gonna do a completionist run of
dark souls three
i mean i don't plan on it but that would
be awesome dark souls 3 is was my first
souls game actually back in 2016.
just dumped his stamina swinging combos
at the air
exactly
i'm i'm teaching my mom how to play
elden ring and i'm convinced she's a
dark souls veteran
man the only game my mom's ever played
was fall guys
she loved fall guys
it got stuck in a tree
and died i had that happen to me with a
death bird in caled
i was really trying to beat this death
bird and caleb
it took me like 20 tries and eventually
it just
flung itself
off a cliff and died it's like thank you
oh now i can go down sweet
oh
okay
i hate death birds dude i hate them
they're terrible terrible terrible
terrible fights
my least favorite
okay
bald guys with mom would be hilarious
you're not wrong okay let's go
underground i really want to do this
good morning good morning good morning
jumped off a ledge
got stuck yourself midair
wasn't even a traditional enemy on your
first death hey that's how it is
all you need two of them dude
all right let's go help uh our boy
did i talk to bach last stream i don't
remember
i think i did
if he's not down here then i'll go talk
the buck
might try and fight radon good luck
it's a good one
wait is it here
yes
what up drake how you doing
we
oh god
we're good
we're good
i had something i want to talk about and
i forgot what it was
oh so someone said dark souls 3 and i
i think this would be a good idea and
you guys can let me know
what if we had a stream
because you guys know that gifted
members just became a thing it's not on
my channel yet because it's like in beta
for all the big channels or whatever
but whenever we get access to that i
think it would be fun
to do
a member thought member of on subathon
you know what i mean
where we have a timer
and i'll play the entire soul series
in one playthrough if we can keep that
timer going so it'd be like a subathon
on twitch but a member thought on
youtube and we can just keep it going
non-stop
i think that'd be fun
so we would go
demon souls dark souls 1 dark souls 2
bloodborne dark souls 3 sakiro elden
ring
but that's only if we keep the timer
going i don't know what i would start it
yet
start it at
but i think that would be cool
i think it'd be like a special stream
that would be fun i have not talked
about okay
we could kill
uh
we could kill the knights cavalry
talk to bach come back here
good playing good playing
yeah demon souls
it's the first uh souls game
when did that game come out like two
thousand
seven oh no
you could summon me and i could help you
smile
thanks for the two bucks i'm not gonna
be doing any summons
i'm just gonna do it all solo man but
thank you i appreciate it
oh there you are
could you help us out
that would be another interesting stream
where we like try and beat the game with
all uh
just summons from the stream that would
be cool
be kind of boring for me but be cool
oh yes demons souls
some claude turned me into a tree
oh what's up mom just breaking the spell
weren't you by the way christy starts in
the chat is my mother
i was pushed out of the cave
told not to come back
the nursery yet
could you help us out colleen oh
what a shame
when they threw me out of the cave
they took everything i owned
and so this is all i have to express my
thanks
zgt mom you can forgive me
[Music]
thanks for the mushroom bach or
if you can afford to wait for a while
i could sneak back into the cave and
bring back something of that rock play
through where you defeat enemies by
altering real use to you they're
garments
right interesting
i'll need a moment
i'm i'm frightened of them
so i have to gather myself
my knees start knocking
just thinking about that god-awful cave
on the shore
right
okay
so now we can go help him
[Music]
over here colleen
over here
agt mommy mama store
oh
there he is
oh
what are you doing here
you must leave this place at once you're
as near the dragon in the lake right
next to us beat you to a pope
he's under uh an arch just like me
i need to go do patches as well
box to be fine guys he's fine
should we do a mama starts or agt mom
plays elden ring stream
that could be a whole video
i'm gonna i'm gonna use this guy
it's estevan
did i not just kill you
bubba
this one
um
this guy makes it easy
it's like golf i like watching but don't
like playing things i'm horrible at
you wouldn't be horrible this this
game's easy right guys
eldon rings easy
oh man dude i cannot wait for dlc
i don't know what they're gonna do for
dlc
but i'm very excited
so you get to the dragon place right
no hit all bosses
i'm not that good at the game
that would take so long
yeah i bet mama store it
or agt mama
agt mom
whatever we want to call her i bet she
had one shot melania
still can't level
i bet she'd one shot him
church of dragon communion
meat
i do want to use these so it's faith and
arcane for these okay
how many of you i i know i asked this
like almost every stream but i'm curious
how many of you guys
uh is eldon ring your first
souls game
is that all that's here
okay
and if this is your first souls game
will you go back and play the other ones
[Music]
a lot of firsts that's cool i love that
[Music]
because usually souls games are very
very very niche very niche
so it's cool for them to like kind of
branch out
okay what else can we do guys
there's just so much we could do
actually
um
um well let's look at our list we have a
list after all
where's my mouse there we are
i can't play any other game now it's
hard to play other games now isn't it
we just beat the beast of pharaoh
missoula right
i think we just beat him
um
where's a bell-bearing hunter out here
wicked we beat the shade we beat the
cemetery shade for sure
we've got
demi human chief is that who i just beat
i think
something like that
wait
we now we gotta go uh
we gotta go see patches
we gotta go
find the roon bear
we can do this when we get one more
stone key
bell bearing hunter is the warmaster
shack how do you get it
how do you spawn it
what do you what do you have to do it's
definitely demi human chief
we just beat the crucible knight
damn
let's go to patches and knights cavalry
next let's let's do that
so you just have to be there at night
that's it
okay
let's let's do that i don't think i've
ever done that i'm not gonna lie
cool
so you go
so i'll go tonight and then we'll warp
okay
what if bernal's there
oh then you rest okay thank you
he's tough yeah but i'm tougher
you see how i beat up that goat
definitely tougher
he's a hard early game boss
is he just as strong as he is in the
shaded castle
oh he disappears okay
i wonder why i need to do more info on
on the bell bearing hunter
i should do a video on him
but i gotta know what i'm talking about
first
okay
so do i rest and then do night again
yo what up glenn
he's still there
or do i gotta leave
and then warp back
names bernal
not seen you before
name's bernard
tarnished just like you
let me ask you something
are you hearing the lands between to
take up the fight
this one near the turtle pope of grace
despite the collapse of the golden order
uh sure yes you're a tarnished through
and through
have to exhaust this dialogue okay thank
you that's the quality needed now more
than ever
i'll buy some interesting bearing the
torch of my battle arts
all i know is the sword
picked up a fair few tricks in my time
too
now's the time to pass them on
to a good and proper tarnished like you
learn skills
uh
parry
quick stop
there's a myriad of battle arts in these
lands that i've yet to discover
mementos of all the warriors who raised
their arms in battle
lost and died the one in caled is harder
than radon all told of true chivalric
romance dang that's how i fell in love
with the sword
and the arts of combat
it grants meaning even to falling in
battle
to death itself
so i i have a question because i have
not looked into uh elmer very much
are the
what is it bell-bearing
the bell bears
are they elmer elemer
or are they different people that just
look the same
well
until we meet again
ooh that did not he sounded kind of sus
right there
okay past time till nightfall
they're different people
it is elmer
all right what am i doing wrong maybe i
gotta warp in
he invades you
hello
just sit down while it's nighttime okay
it says
night chat kind of covers it though
a role play build you guys want me to
role play
that'd be interesting
need to fast travel back to the same
grace
after you wait until night so you want
me to wait until night again
and then
go like teleport to this grace that i'm
at
let's try that because this isn't
working
[Music]
and then i'm working
hello
renault what you doing bro
oh it's
okay
okay okay
walk into the shack
rp walk
damn
well
we'll come back to that
when you rest your teleport you reset
time to morning
and it did say night
we'll come back we'll come back maybe we
gotta get out of there and do something
else and come back to it
yeah cuz bernal is in volcano manor so
maybe he doesn't spawn until we we
actually get to volcano manor
that's possible
hey yo what up
and my character is really strong right
now
man
easy peasy
what up pascal how are you today
yeah our katana is really just that good
because that's
i didn't even make them bleed
you can do that early in the game we did
multiple playthroughs okay
let's try
should i just try again
it says bernal is still there
i love the knights calvary too they're
very cool
hello bell bearer
oh got our boy here
i'm gonna sit
still in there
we're trying to get a bell barrier to
show up pascal right now
put it on night and then rest again okay
night
resting
again reset the game
that will work
come from another grace and then run to
the shack oh my goodness
i don't think resetting the game will do
anything
yeah i bought two things off of them
pretty sure it's still night
definitely
okay bernal's there for now
ah hello
glad to see you safe
here to learn a battle art or two
i bought these two things
why can you buy no skill
no skill
until we meet again
either glitching of the story hasn't
progressed enough
because the wiki says to just rest at
night twice
it's really weird
oh it's for shields
let me try again
who's your favorite npc oh man that's
tough oh he's not there
he's not there what do i do do i get up
i don't want to [ __ ] it
why did that randomly
okay i think i got to get up
[Music]
oh man that's tough
dang dude
dude he looks so cool look at that
ow
yeah you can't reach that far
this guy might have the coolest design
no i threw
oh
i was doing so good
i threw though dude i was i was pressing
roll and my character was just like no
bernoull
i threw man i really
did f
oh come on
now what
why did it work
thank you sneezy i'm glad you like him
man
okay what did i do before
i went over here
okay okay
past time
i did morning i'm stupid
nightfall
stand up
oh he's not there
bro
you get some hits in
ow that hurt
oh those are three those are three
[Music]
don't grab me
i pressed roll and i had no stamina
that's why
that's risky biscuit dude
oh minecraft bro
don't know why i did that
dude how do you dodge that
i'm the best
first try right guys
ooh what do we get for that let's go
find out
all right i got a level
what kind of build am i going for here
apparently decks and strength
hmm
one more mind
it all matter we can always change it
after we beat ranala okay
think you can buy unlimited bones
what would i use bones for
let's find out
gostick
it's called bone peddler okay so found
by hunting beast
bound by honey and particularly large
beasts
uh commonly used to make disposable
weapons
okay
okay
that's useful if you got like a bow
build
okay
that's worth
let's go to patches now
now i can't
kill patches
because
we're doing
all quest lines
or do we even want to do patches of
quest line because he's on the boss list
to kill
what's up gilgamesh
i'll leave it up to chat
do his quest and kill him well his quest
is very far down the line
good doggy
i was petting him
it is we're gonna try a hundred percent
so we should
we'll do everything we think is worth
what's that guy doing up there
how are you meek
welcome welcome
thought you'd help yourself to my man's
personal belongings i
well well well
let's wait for europe euro makes this
this guy can kill you so fast
you're uh
you're uh
thank you
wait what i ran too far away
i don't even know you could do that
interesting
ah we meet again
to afford nereus and escaped
fortune must smile upon you indeed
i am yura
as you might recall
hunter of bloody fingers
tarnished held in thrall but i can do
some impressions i'm not bad at it
who stalk their own
you stay the path well well well
you're certain to face more of them just
remember
no kinship with their elk remains
their madness precludes it
ironic
don't let your emotions stay your blade
considering you go mad later on let's
try that again
[Music]
euro is really cool
hello
we might have to go down here and rest
all right if you guys want to avoid that
just don't
just run away
we'll go to patches just since we're
here come back to that
oh it goes crazy see i haven't done the
euro quest line yet
can you do an agtj compression no i'm
not very good at that
i don't want to embarrass myself
do you guys like that impression i was
just kidding when i said that
dude i want to know godfrey's
workout routine
i think radon's just a giant part giant
well well well
the gods demand repentance
cough up your coins all
[Music]
likes a ball-headed brute you know
i yield yield
you can't harm a yielding man
you guys know that if you summon patches
in the radon fight he literally just
leaves
he just leaves
ah
well what do you know
you're tarnished like me now how did i
get that wrong
i took you for a demi-human or some such
an innocent mistake i assure you
well walter couldn't radon just tell
melania he didn't kick nap malay or
nicola
um well if he could talk which i don't
think he can because he's nuts now
um
i believe melania was there
because mogwin's palace is directly
below where we fight radon and caleb
so i think she was on the right track
a true man of reason
just what i like about you
i'm patches
patches the untethered
tarnished like you only
free spirit gee bruh nomadic you might
say
only for now very true retired soldiers
turned bandits uh they're paying for my
gruel
in exchange for my well
showing them the ropes but honestly
this looting bracket is bloody
terrifying
frankly do you guys think
that elden ring is in the same world as
the dark souls and bloodborne and
everything i'll be ready to wheel and
deal come next time
[Laughter]
because why would patches be here
i guess even patches is even in
bloodborne by the way
he's a spider in bloodborne
with the his head don't forget to pop
back for another visit friend
i'll be ready to wheel and deal come
next time
oh okay
i think so but i don't want to say it
out loud yeah exactly because then
you'll have a bunch of people be like
well
no
you know people have a tendency to do
that
i think he exists because he's like
basically a meme for from software
yeah
he's there because he's like an iconic
character in all of the games it doesn't
mean the games are connected
all right let's try that again
[Music]
yeah he's a from software mascot yeah
might not need you europe well never
mind
thanks for the help yura appreciate it
man did a lot there
mid air knock downs
very nice
absolutely bonnie mate
okay now
chad where's the cave
that has the roon bear in it
where is that
did we help out blide yet i think we did
yeah we definitely did
where where's the roon bear
cave
[Music]
his dagger does a lot of bleed
is it in the miss one
well well well who has a bloody finger
now
not you
weeping peninsula
it is very short though but it does a
lot of bleed damage
eventually
is 100 on this game even possible we're
going to find out and do our best
is it right here
that's a cave no that can't be it
i think unsheath is one of the best
skills in the game
further up the ravine this way
what happens if we just go down here
what what's over here
i'm gonna find out i'm just curious now
yeah do you i think melania is actually
blind
and she's still as strong as she is
cave near the start of weeping
i think i know what you're talking about
but i want to see what's over here
am i even going the right oh my god
hello
all right we're going over here
don't talk lord theory someone from
reddit might be here god
not a fan of reddit
this game hasn't gotten old yet not to
me i freaking love this game i've been
waiting for this game for a long time
man
i'm enjoying it
i hate these things
it's a trap
oh i might die here
this is not where we want to be friends
cool
[Music]
excellent excellent
excellent good to see
perfect
perfect
stop throwing things at me it's cringe
okay
i want to go this way though
did i or did i not jump over that it
doesn't matter
hopefully elder scrolls 6 is good
i don't know man
they didn't do very good with uh fallout
76
ignoring
nothing ruins your vibe like an imp
inflicting blood loss exactly
hello grave warden duelist
you're a big boy
your attacks ever stop
oh okay okay
ow
backstabbing
well
vanish night
egg bowl
yeah he has he staggered to everything
yeah that was uh
that was pretty easy
we'll take it let's see how many more we
have to do in limb grave
i i think what my character build is
showing right now is that unsheathed is
overpowered
okay so
we beat the bell bearing hunter
right
is that who we fought
grave warden duelist bell bearing hunter
um
i don't know where a death root is
knights cavalry
should i i guess i shouldn't check
patches
where's the scaly miss where's a scaly
misbegotten
because i'm just trying to here i can
help you guys see because chat gets in
the way on the screen for you
i want to know where the rune bear is
you i think you guys told me
don't i have no idea oh i do i do i do
we could do this
did i beat the mariner
okay mariner and then rune bear
it's in mourn tunnel
okay thank you
you guys are extremely helpful and i
appreciate it
okay
i already forgot what i want to do it's
great
is it in a cave near limb grave isn't
this is weeping peninsula right
right here
trying to think
because there's a cave over here that i
have not done yet we might as well just
go do it
try fingers
butthole
but all
let's see
so does edgar just not bury his daughter
he just leaves her here
you see this
[Music]
he just
he just leaves her there man
what a savage
he just [ __ ] off
that is so sad
his daughter becomes someone else that's
true
at least we think so
got captain carter
i'm
95 percent sure she becomes hayata yeah
look at this guy
hey
that's what we needed baby
sorry eagle
all right we about find out what's over
here
a lot of jellyfish
i figured we'd just do this all in order
right we go from like limb grave to
lakes of lurinia to you know i mean like
just go in order like just try and
finish everything
irina's body never
unloads man
she really got the short end of the
stick didn't she
i'm not even gonna fight these guys i
don't like him
we'll try and survive by running we're
here for the boss
bruh
bruh
okay so that tries to kill you
what's your least favorite regular mob
probably these little imps
or the birds
birds are close
dark souls 3 it's the it's the dogs
to find some new armor oh here we go
jesus
are you freaking kidding me
i'm out of here
oh the lobsters are hard too
no please no
why i don't have stamina
should probably lock on
oh i'm struggling here guys
that's okay
all these things freak me out man
come on
okay that felt faster than the other
time sir
oh god
please
[Music]
those bosses are terrifying
but we got it done
more dangerous than the imps
i don't know when the ink the imps gang
up on you dude
you didn't have to fight him for an hour
plus we're actually doing pretty good
but that was not the rune bear
when in doubt hug it out agreed
okay
i'm gonna go up here
you have memberships on this channel of
course
mobile makes joining very weird
but it is an option
it's linked in the description as well
oh my god i haven't even said this
either
i started a patreon
because i was told that i should
that's a good way to give um some people
who want to support the channel even
more benefits
um
so that's linked in the description as
well guys
if you want
it'll give you
early access to lore videos so i think i
would put them on patreon like a day
early
before they get posted on youtube and
then obviously there's no ads with that
as well
if you're curiou if you're wanting to do
that
um
and it's where you'll get
really cool merch in the future
because
my sister
just graduated from college
with a degree in art and design claps in
the chat for meg
way to go meg
just graduated college and she's gonna
help me design some really cool stuff
dude
uh like elden ring uh agt jake
merchandise
so i'm really excited about that
it's not done yet obviously but that's
where you'd get it it would be on
patreon
so that's i think that's linked at the
top of the description
so if you want to check that out go
check that out
ripple piece
yep dogs are the worst enemy clearly
but yeah no ads uh you get it a day
early
then you a day earlier than youtube does
so
up to you
and i would appreciate it very much
because it really helps the channel out
a lot
shut up meg
trust me we've said that to her
more times than you can count
should we do the turtle thing here no
it's not even worth
where is this roon bear chat
i'm struggling
um
shut up meg
oh i love doggies
i love my dog joy
is it not hashtag worth i think it's
worth it's up to you though
little south of you you guys are saying
top and then south
so over here
all right whoops
east of first weeping grace
and clearly i don't know where that is
it's in a deep first forest at the top
like here okay
i think you're right
when you chase for an hour and a half by
dogs you'll understand
okay thank you
yeah there's a dude that shows you where
it is right but it's just like over here
got it thank you thank you
yup
this is it
brain fart
how do you give away runes
is that even possible i ain't falling
for this trick
a pickle turtleneck
i have been contacted by so many
websites to do like sponsored things to
like for their website that gives away
runes
and i was like
no that seems very sketchy
can't see
oh you can drop runes and co-op
interesting
still seems sketchy
that just looked like an illusionary
wall to me i don't know why
rats
there's a lot of bones down here
you can't drop runes anywhere lies
the hell
i don't know i've never tried it
i'm just reading chat
aha
we have found him
rp walk
pow
oh that's unfair
we're going for it
sick
we did it
we did it we did it we did it yeah yeah
we did it
four playthroughs never found this guy
right here
or the cave entrance is right here
destin death god slayer black flame or
red lightning
i think destin death is sick the
the black blade is probably one of the
coolest weapons in the game after you
beat malacath
thanks kevin
i'm glad you like him
i'm glad you like them
what level are you right now
i don't know why i did that
37
37
okay let's update
update our list it
we beat the rune bear
we
i guess i haven't beaten the tibia i
know where that is
i swear we beat the black knife assassin
we did a hundred percent
archery burial watchdog storm foot and
impaler which one was i which one did i
just fight against
yeah but there's one in limb grave
i don't know where scaly misbegotten is
impaler okay thank you
we got death bird
storm foot
grafted scion oh my god how do we get
over there again i don't remember
guardian golem
what is that
wait no no no no no this is what i just
thought
i think these two are there's two of
them in one boss fight if i remember
right
thanks so so lead no i don't
i think is mourn tunnel just east of the
herd tree
mourn tunnel
yes the spreadsheet is in the
description
guardian gollum is a literal giant golem
okay i was wrong okay
my bad so it was the impaler
my memory is terrible
okay got it
i like how right when i said that like
four people popped up here um
let's do let's do this one and then make
sure i'll make sure we did the tibia and
then we'll go to the
the
dungeon below where we first start
can it's there
there's the village
got it
i swear i did this but could still be
wrong
okay i did perfect
now let's go down under
blue dancer charm
man there's so many things to remember
here we go
kenneth is such an l name
i'm planning on getting another dog chat
and i want to name him kevin what do you
think
why i wanted to jump onto the pot
there we go
yeah warm face is very scary
hello okay
oh yeah
instant death chariot of course
i knew it bastard
[Music]
you go halfway up don't you you mother
trucker dude
[Music]
i'm scared
all right
bet
i've always insta died to these
always close one
oh god
i do this for safety might not have been
worth it right here
what the
[ __ ]
you
oh no
dang dude
i hate this boss
at least you get to be right outside the
door
give me my rooney voice
cool oh oh good
good
that's great
what
how do you know what it what what's his
arm
i'm in i can see inside this guy
okay
why did he not spit fire this time
what
that was weird
cool cool
excellent excellent
what
is happening
so
please be done
i can't even tell like what's happening
with my character
oh i thought i'd be underneath them dude
this spot sucks man
no
you're not doing that
oh
jeez
very unenjoyable boss fight there
but it is over
gg gg
malakath gave me the most issues and i
refuse to fight him again i love the
malacath fight and i struggle with him a
lot at first but malacath is a great
boss fight
beating this boss is a real
treat
one good one
very good
all right
i feel like i need more mind to be
honest i don't know we'll see where this
this weird build leads us
and again we can always change it
when we beat ranala
okay
so
back to our list
i heard someone compare this boss fight
to a cracked out dog trying to chase a
bee in a tiny ass room
i think that's a good comparison i
really do
we need to find the guardian golem i
don't know what that is
no idea where miranda the blighted bloom
is
um
we've beaten the tibia and we've beaten
the tree spirit
i think that's very accurate very good
you eventually want 60. yeah i'm yeah
we'll we'll get there
it's not super important right
now not not crazy
um mad pumpkin head we know where that
is that's um
lion guardian
dude there's there's a lot of bosses i
don't know where these are okay
let's go beat uh egghead over here
somewhere
here
son of a gun
[Music]
yeah that's right in front of selling
[Music]
it's on the list
yeah mad pumpkin head is uh very easy
man my mark was perfect
now
dude
leave me be
lag
all right
i keep hitting his head
there we go
you got your hunter trophy nights nice
nice
and you're hungry for more
we need dlc don't we
we really need some dlc well i wouldn't
say really need it but
it's coming i know they're making dlc
they have to be
hi celine tarnished are we yes
no wonder you should turn up here
i am selling her sorcerer quite plainly
why are you here
i want to learn sorcery
oh well perhaps nurture will defy nature
with a bit of luck
but one must choose one's masters wisely
thank you for the subs guys
we're getting close to 50k
very close
do you still wish to learn from me
so thank you
yes i do
well you are a piece of work
very well
you are now my protege in glenstone
sorcery but i refuse to coddle
or cast kind words
never
anticipate grievances
young apprentice
okay
don't want anything
why not in thought yes
i want a new bloodborne
i'm pretty sure
do you guys think they're going to make
bloodborne 2
because i don't
i don't think they're going to make
bloodborne 2.
i would love it but i don't think they
will
and i hope they do
but i don't
just sad
um
okay so you said for miranda blighty
broom i think it's in the cave
underneath the westernmost church and
weeping
okay west
it's like down here
ps4 exclusive
yeah
are you uh is your channel only based on
elden ring or do you do videos on other
games as well right now i only do videos
on elden ring
and i don't plan on doing anything else
for now
no idea what holds
what what the future holds
i would much rather punch self elvis
celebus in the face
sell this is the most annoying character
in this game
i mean they did dark souls one two and
three
yeah i just i feel like those were if
anything they could do bloodborne 2 i
don't see them doing a sakuro 2 at all
i really don't
although i would love it
i think they're going to be working on
elden ring for a long time like they're
just going to make dlc on this game
um hopefully they make a bloodborne port
that
must be down there i hope they make a
bloodborne port to pc and like update
the graphics and like make a remake of
it that would be incredible
is this it ew what the [ __ ] is this
oh oh
oh
oh
oh
leave me alone
bloodborne depends on sony i don't know
how long their contract is
could be forever
what the
excuse me
calm down
uh
sex jump sex dungeon vibes
oh you're alive
what the f
oh this is selling
it will do no good i swear it
and yet you persist
you frothing degenerates
oh my
i have not been here before no
i have not done your requests
i've seen her quest but i haven't done
it
i think myself all she says
so should i go back
what in tarnation
i want to find the flower
where's the flower
i can make lore videos without doing
every quest line
your foreheads
oh
but i have seen how it ends
on the east a little bit north of church
between church and evergale on the ledge
it's like over here
i thought sony commissioned the game
like they did with demon souls i mean
they made a remake of demon souls so
it's possible
[Music]
i don't know why i do that
uh the bloom is on the
on the east a little bit
okay well i'll keep going east
i thought that was a door for a second
is it on the beach
i'm right above it okay
so it is down there
ew these things are gross
i'm confused
yeah i'm assuming a remake would only be
on ps5 yeah
ed pingu
wonder why these guys are out here
between evergale and church i swear
that's where i kind of was
[Music]
no they're like
i forget what they're called
ping pingins pingins
something like that
okay he said between
church and the evergale
right
thank you thank you
yeah you can make
you can make lore videos without knowing
every single little detail about the
game
because i'm assuming uh
you know
selling doesn't
who knows
but yeah come on
you goose
there's still areas i'm
exploring and have never found before
it's gross down here man
leave me alone man
thank you
this has got to be it
yay oh god
kidding me
well
that was pretty easy
i love the fact that the more technology
advances the more consoles become jet
turbines dude they really are like if if
you're not getting a pc
i mean i play on pc
little vigor won't hurt right
i'm pretty i pretty much this point put
points into whatever until we get to
ranala and then we can just change stuff
around if need be all right let's check
our list again
also i probably won't be streaming for
too long today because i want to see the
end of the um
the pga championship today
my pc sounds like a jet turbine too
that's that's gonna happen and it's
gonna happen okay we beat mad pumpkin
head
um
we beat miranda we gotta find the scaly
misbegotten
we found patches but we're not gonna do
that for a while
um
i have no idea where lion guardian is
let me look that up let's let's find the
lion guardian i don't think i've ever
done that boss fight
yeah i used to play counter strike on my
macbook pro
and now i have a very nice pc which i'm
very happy about
lion
guardian location elden ring
yeah it's a real it's a real fight
let's see
stormville fort gale
fort gale huh
well that's in caleb dude
is really counting it as stormville
i guess that is lim grave isn't it okay
so we got we got to go into stormville
to do that
okay
i just thought it was like a something
on the like in the boss room but it's
not a boss fight
not boss room in in the castle
what's up me man how are we doing today
oh it is chat
it says this enemy is not a boss
this enemy does not respawn once killed
oh why is it on this list then
oh
all right well i'm checking it off
we'll kill it when we go in there
guardian golem where is that
yeah that's i think that's what it means
mambo but it's not
guardian
golem
elden ring
location
high road cave
and that's where you get the blue dancer
charm someone said that earlier
guardian golem on the high road cave
he's at the top of the ravine
wasn't i there
okay let's go
behind a waterfall holy [ __ ]
so do i have to go
this way then
three
oh god can we reach that
we'll go up here
do you have a streaming schedule i don't
currently i don't because youtube is
very like
it seems like you guys really do like
youtube streams though
but obviously youtube's made for videos
i would like to stream more on here
i've had a great time streaming on
youtube compared to twitch
that looks like death
is that a merchant dude how like
how have i found so many new things
today
you guys are very helpful
might not be a merchant
might be a cave entrance
wait oh there we go
i'm stuck in a tree man
the heck is this
turtleneck meet you
[Music]
all right what am i missing
fam found it
found it
another new cave i've never been in
youtube's easier to navigate than twitch
i don't know about that with live
streams though
live stream navigation on youtube is
pretty bad in my opinion
or it could be better
i'm sorry little doggy
i don't want the hurt too
turtleneck supposed to be a pun
i don't know about a pun
thank you lance
i think that's a legit turtleneck
you mean like the shirt maybe
they both can be better yeah
twitch is very meta-oriented where i
felt like youtube is very creator
oriented does that make sense
damn this cave is dope
i hear the waterfall you're talking
about oh god
oh my god dude
i've never been here
350 plus hours in this game i've never
been here
wow
what's the twitch meta e girls
no
there's plenty of
there's plenty of other streams that are
wildly successful that don't do that
dude
you can drown
smithing stone twos
get some rooney boys
yeah this game is cool
do i have to jump
um
okay
you think if i stream with no shirt i'd
be number one
shamsheer what is that that's cool
leave me be
sorry i was itching my nose
who are you
those
one of those big boys
um
yo
things are so creepy man
favorite weapon type definitely katanas
i love katanas oh you're not dead
now you are
it's a millicent's weapon
land octopus ovary
stop it stop it
man
i think i would like to take a very
short break from making videos and just
kind of stream for a while
because
videos have been very stressful lately
and it's been growing the channel like
[ __ ] wildfire it's been amazing don't
get me wrong but the
the other things that have happened with
it have been so [ __ ] stressful it's
might need like a week
to just like stream and hang out
whoa
thank you ash
it's a big
gate
dark souls 2 vibes
i can't
yes i can
oh my god
you're not dead okay
blue dancer charm huh
raises attack power with lower equipment
load
ooh
so if i just run around naked i'm on
poggers
giga chad
the lighting's too good for dark souls
2.
listen there are good things about dark
souls 2 and there are bad things
i'm like level 38
anthony i think let me check
always better to have a clearer mind
yeah it i'm not i'm not worried about
reddit i'm not i'm not worried about
anything i just need like a mental break
because it's it's been
i mean you guys think about it bro like
a month ago we were at
a thousand subscribers
and now we're almost at 50k in a month
like that that is
kind of insane
you know
it's definitely a beginner cave
for level 40.
and it wouldn't be that long i would
take
i also would stream because i like
streaming
there's a big difference between like
posting a video and streaming so i think
i would just stream for like the next
week and just kind of relax you know
because i would like to finish this
series
is it more lucrative to live stream or
make vids definitely to make videos
depends like that depends on your guys's
generosity and
you know how much you super chat and and
donate or or whatever that's completely
up to you guys whereas making a video is
based on how good the video is and how
many views it gets
yep oh that's pretty i don't see myself
slipping
choder
i'm i'm more prepared for this than you
guys think
i've been i've been making content for
probably half a decade at this point so
and we're just now figuring it out
but i i mean i streamed on twitch for
four years
and got 20 000 subscribers i i got
partnered on twitch and everything just
from like uh when rocket league got
really really popular for like a month
i don't know if you guys know about
rocky league or not but that game went
wildly popular just for a month when it
went free to play
and that's how i got partnered on twitch
because i was a coach
and i i did freelance coaching for
rocket league and everyone wanted to
learn how to get better and
so that's and then i had like that super
popularity for like a month
and then it was just gone so i was
waiting for elden ring to come out and
here we are
aren't feeling
oh it would definitely show yeah i agree
with that showed 100
like if you're not right mentally it
will show in the videos for sure
what led you into elden ring bro i have
been waiting for this game my whole life
like
uh
i in 2016
i didn't even know what dark souls was i
i am your very very typical
call of duty gamer
that
like
i just played call of duty and i played
zombies with my friends that's all i did
and played minecraft
right that's it
i was a very typical casual
casual gamer who played cod right
and then in 2016 i don't know what it
was but
i got recommended on my xbox store
dark souls 3 and i was like what is this
about this looks cool
and i tried dark souls 3
and i absolutely
loved it
that was my first dark souls game in
2016.
like it i played it so many times over
like i probably have thousands of hours
in dark souls 3.
um i used to speed run it like it was so
much fun
and i was like i'm going to go play the
other games
played dark souls 1 loved it played dark
souls 2. i think it's terrible like for
a dark souls game but it's still a
pretty good game um
i bought a ps4 just so i could play
bloodborne
got a ps4 just so i could play
bloodborne bloodborne is like probably
one of the best games of all time
um
love bloodborne it was one of my later
games though that i played
and then sakiro came out i'm like oh
that's made by from software immediately
played sekiro absolutely loved it and
i've been waiting for elden ring ever
since man so i'm like i'm such a typical
typical gamer that played call of duty
until rocket league came out
and
i just
i i played rocket league for six years
guys i was a top 100 player i was i
played on professional teams i was a
professional coach
um
got popular on twitch for one singular
month
and and that was it and it was like okay
it's time to move on to something else i
heard eleanor was coming out and i just
kind of waited for it to come out and
here we are that's that's my gaming
story there's there's a lot more that's
happened in my life that led me here
[Music]
my father died last year and
he was a die hard diablo and skyrim
player
i know he would have loved this game oh
i'm sorry man
i bet he would have
that's cool
i bet he would have
two full days 48 hours in play time and
eldon ring is still surprising me trey i
just found like three different areas
that i haven't ever been in before
i'm like i'm at 350 hours man and i'm
still finding new stuff
absolutely are you a full-time creator
at well i go to school too i'm almost
done with college
i have one more year left of college um
i'm getting a degree in digital
marketing
just to kind of help with what i'm doing
now but my full-time job is is content
creation yeah absolutely
no i've never played uh kingsfield
no
yeah but uh
a lot of stuff has happened here like
i had a youtube channel that you guys
probably don't know about
called jake from state farm
and i think i got i made valorant
tutorials on omen the character omen if
you've played ballerin
we got 20 000 subscribers on there
and then
for me that game became like just not
something i wanted to keep going with
so
eventually i just stopped uploading to
that channel and deleted it i just
deleted it i didn't want anything to do
with it anymore
and i made this channel for
pretty much just elden ring
yeah we've done a lot man
i should i should probably make a video
going over
the journey it's taken to get here
because my life is a [ __ ]
interesting journey to say the least
i'm trying to get a ps5 to ash so that i
can play on i want to play demon souls
really bad
i'm i'm still looking for a ps5
okay what's next
we gotta go
okay
let's see
let's check our list again
i have to say the armor choices are
disappointing they only seem to push you
towards one build
i think they're pretty much just for
looks trey i don't i don't think they're
like meant to be actual armor it's kind
of like uh
it's kind of like bloodborne where
bloodborne didn't have like any actual
armor sets it's all just like style
points
okay we just beat guardian golem
where's scaly misbegotten that's up next
that's what we're going for
hey
guys pascal just became a patron
i appreciate that thank you very much
first patron on patreon
thank you
thank you
i think you should try darkest dungeon
if you like dark souls and bloodborne
i will i will
nicey
mourn tunnel
i've been there bro
but i appreciate that so again i'm gonna
talk about patreon again really quick
since we're taking like kind of a little
break but
patreon you get 24 out 24 hour early
access to any new videos coming out on
youtube
uh with no ads so if you get ads on
youtube and you want to see the video
early before everyone else on youtube
does you can become a patreon it'll be
uploaded there
um
and i'm also working with my sister
who just graduated with a degree in art
and design um on some agt jake
elden ring merch
that's gonna come out in the future but
you'll have access to that there as well
and then you get a discord role called
tarnish warrior which is kind of cool
too so
go check out the patreon it's in the
description
if you want those little benefits go for
it
thanks wish you could upgrade armor i do
too and i wish you could put armor on
torrent
i don't know why they didn't do that
i hope some more players actually watch
my alden ring stuff
if you make good content you're good
at least that's what i think
okay let's see scaly misbegotten
miss
begotten
in the morn tunnel you're right i just
don't know where more tunnel is
dark and hidden tunnel that is inhabited
by misbegottens and miners
wait what
oh god i got it yep i know where that is
it's
right there
right there
let's get it
do you think either a show or movie is
likely
of elden ring
no
no
i
i very much doubt it
it would be interesting but
very unnecessary
okay i killed the avatar right yeah i
gotta go over here
why not i just i don't think it would
adapt well
i think it's meant to be a video game
hi dougie
have you worked other jobs yes i
have i talked to i think i talked about
this on stream once but i used to be a
professional golfer
i played golf in college
um and i actually dropped out of college
to play on a pro tours
in florida
arizona texas
all over the place for years
uh i injured my right wrist
and i couldn't do that anymore or not
not as well as i
used to obviously
i think it's down here
this is terrifying
i'm gonna die if i drop down there i
know it
oh my god there's another spot
i might take the l here fam let's find
out
best player in the game
i did that for a long time i was a um
teaching pro in golf for a long time too
there it is
i like taught people how to play golf
did that for a while
then started making content and here we
are
saw that
uh similar to level upgrades and
requiring more runes it would be great
if weapon upgrades just required more
smithing stones instead of different
tiered stones
i mean they've always done tiered stones
it's not bad
i wouldn't mind that
you must be rich nope not rich at all i
will do 27.
golf is definitely not just for rich
people
we were uh poor as hell honestly growing
up not poor as hell but
not rich
now we're doing pretty good
you dead bro
ooh northman i've heard of that show
is it good
i feel like i actually am doing more
damage
what's your favorite souls like game
i don't think i've i mean
if you're meaning like any other game
besides like the souls games i wouldn't
know i haven't played them i don't think
[Music]
it's amazing okay where can i watch that
actually i'll find it
northman northman northman
that sounds cool
do you think dropping out of college
then was a good idea
uh in hindsight now probably not
but
life is life
it goes on
we're here
i don't have any regrets for that
bro
there we go
amazon prime all right
um
who's your favorite pro golfer rory
mcelroy for sure
here we go here's the boss gotta be the
boss
i met rory
very nice guy
so it's just a regular misbegotten oh
man
jeez
an anchor
cool
yeah everyone had a tough day yesterday
it's it's why i'm not gonna stream for
very long today i want to watch the rest
of the
the pga
i i think i am going to stream most of
this week though guys i love streaming
on youtube it's been super fun i would
i'm really curious to see what would
happen if i stream more on here
um and kind of took a a very small break
from making videos
you're too strong bro i'm level
40 not even that good
college is a lie i dropped out of
college because i didn't know what i
wanted to get a degree in i shouldn't
have gone to college that
that is um the biggest tip to anyone any
one of you guys who are in high school
or early college and you don't know what
to do
don't go to college if you don't know
what you want to get a degree in because
i had no freaking idea
um
i should have gone to community college
and did just did my gen ed so that when
i did know what i wanted to do i could
just go
to a to a big school after that
um
that would have been the right plan
absolutely
but i dropped out i originally went to
college because i got a scholarship to
play golf so i was like well hell yeah
i'm going to do that now
uh and i just wasn't ready to go i was
not ready to go to to college yet
and uh
i dropped out because i knew i wanted to
play golf
so i did that
and
now i now i know what i want to do in
college so now i'm back in college
scandinavian studies cool that's very
interesting
we're almost done with limgrave
almost done
let's find
how do we get to the grafted scion we
might have to leave this one in patches
for a later time
let's find the
stormfoot burial watchdog
hey i
i did not like college but there are
plenty of people out there who should go
to college because they know what
they're doing
and it's a good experience for them just
for me it was not
depends on the type of person that you
are
watchdog
a storm foot
norse mythology that is
actually sick
okay storm foot catacombs
which is
okay
we should do death bird as well
yeah we got to go through the belfries
to get back to the grafted zion
i can't use magic with this hammer
weapon he uses a stuff
uses a staff
you mean the all-knowing you gotta you
gotta be gideon to do that
it looks like that
is
around here
and then where's the death bird in
limgrave
oh i thought we crashed i think my
controller is reconnecting
yup did you hear about the true co-op
mod coming on the 27th nope
that would be great
crystal darts stunned the stone imps in
the watchdogs
[Music]
i did where did i hear that from did i
hear that in one of vati's videos
i think so but yeah that is very cool
college does this brilliant thing they
convince you you're gonna change
everything
you're not wrong depends on the type of
person you are
[Music]
gideon's the real hero
i don't know about that
i've been thinking of moving to europe
pascal
for a while actually
it might be a few years before i do that
though
what does this guy say a proper death
means returning to the earth tree
have patience until the time comes and
the room and the roots call to you
monkas
immediate
blood loss and he's not even done
dude
stop moving
please
jeez
where in europe
i've been looking at denmark
portugal
spain
norway
those are my main ones
these amps are a meme bro
i see you there
i'm running i ain't dealing with this
i'm scared
what
hello
what's the point of this
college is glorified high school
college can definitely help you get a
really good job
but
if you don't know what you're going to
do there i would not recommend going to
college
bruh
like
wow dude
i couldn't do anything
oh that's so annoying
have you finished elden ring once
oh yeah
oh yeah
many a time
curse you in these traps
oh they stay down though
stay to the south in portugal why's that
i got my degree in mcdonald's
registration
hell yeah dude
better gets you the bank
i should probably get my things
favorite ending ronnie's ending for sure
absolutely
i hate you
[Music]
i did complete elder scrolls online once
and
know how to beat it again but i don't
know how popular it currently is i do
not think that game is popular but i
could be wrong
may chaos
take
the world
yes i have been talking to all of your
wives
chat
which all of them are ronnie isn't it
don't lie all of them are ronnie
north is too messy south is where the
good beaches and good weather is at
all right
i'm down
didn't i already fight this thing
it's just on its own
ow
oh yeah you don't stagger at all
so hard
what are we doing man
you're dead
you did
i just love running around
don't let this distract you from the
fact that fia bangs a living corpse
absolutely does
she does and she likes it
she's cool with it
yeah fia gives us hugs
you think i care
all right where's the where's the death
bird
sometimes all i want is a hug
that's all i need
oxymoron
via's mommy material
potential potential
where is it where's the death bird is it
um
is it down here
really
oh i know where it is
it's over here
it's like right in this area at night
there's two
oh i'm killing one for the list
i don't know if i can [ __ ] kill a
death bird right now to be honest with
you
it's gonna be hard
yeah it spawns over here
yeah there's one in caitlyn
there's a bunch of death birds
i i hate fighting death birds though
they are my least favorite thing to
fight in this game
oh death right and death birds are
different oh my god
of course they are there you are
yeah death bird
what a weird [ __ ] boss man
are you [ __ ] kidding me you little
goat
what a brave goat
stop
thank you
stop
thank you
not good not good
stagger
stop pecking me dog
i always get knocked off a horse back
fighting in a horse back
don't eat me
stagger please
that was close
there we go
all right that wasn't that bad
not that bad
blue feathered branch sword what does
that do
raises defense when hp is low
lit
that's lit
that's all i have to say to you
yep
the camera made me nauseous as well i
think that's everything
is that every game here everything here
might be
now where do we go
oh cole's playing apex
i might call it there for today and we
can pick it up again tomorrow
you guys want me to stream tomorrow
because i really want to watch the end
of the pga
could today the other death bird
giga chad
play sekiro
listen
that could be a thing
i would love to play sakiro on stream
that'd be great
i think everyone wants to see elden ring
for now
we should do that in the future that'd
be fun
yeah i think i'm going to stream again
tomorrow because
i love streaming on here it's been great
um today's just kind of a special day to
watch the pga and hang out with the
family since tomorrow's monday um
so yeah i i'll be back tomorrow around
the same time like 10 11 in the morning
and
we'll take it from there all right
uh
again i'm gonna plug the patreon if you
guys want to see youtube videos a day
earlier than everyone on youtube does
with no ads at all join the patreon
there's gonna be really cool uh agt jake
elden ring merch on there like really
soon in the future
um
and then i've got some other stuff
planned for it as well i'm even planning
on maybe even doing golf lessons on
there but i'm not sure yet so
anyway check out the patreon i'd really
appreciate it if you did
really helps out the channel all the all
the proceeds that go to that just help
in uh funding like making new content
and better content and everything like
that so
appreciate you did follow me on twitter
instagram whatever the hell you want to
subscribe
i'll be back tomorrow
so have a great rest of your day
enjoy the pga if you guys like golf
that's what i'm about to go do
i play i played sifu sodapop i did i
love sifu that could be another fun game
anyway i'm out of here guys i will see
you all tomorrow have a great rest of
your day peace love thanks for the
support
bye bye bye